I want to follow up a little bit about
Donald Trump's completely abortive
attempts to reach out to the black
community Trump said okay what's the
most obviously offensive way to pander
to black voters this is probably not
what he thought but this is what he did
I'm gonna go to Detroit and go to a
black church and sort of try to dance
except he didn't really know what to do
when it looked incredibly awkward so
Trump shows up at great faith ministries
a non-denominational Church in Detroit
sitting in a pew at the front of the
congregation took a selfie with a church
member at one point held a baby over his
shoulders at another point addressed the
congregation and he addressed what what
is largely a black audience saying that
for so long the african-american church
has been the conscience of this country
that's just so so true the
african-american faith community has
been one of God's greatest gifts to
America and its people super sincere
sounding I mean why would anyone doubt
the sincerity of Donald Trump here and
here is how Donald Trump then further
appealed to the people in that room and
I'll put up a quote from his little
speech when I see wages falling people
out of work I know the hardships this
inflicts and I am determined to do
something about it I will do something
about it I do get things done I will
tell you I'm going to get things done
it's not really a good idea to just
accept these broad and unsubstantiated
claims from Trump when it comes to
economic stewardship when his businesses
have filed for bankruptcy multiple times
and he's done worse running the
businesses than he would have by just
letting his entire inheritance from his
dad sit in a bank account not exactly
the guy when I hear him say hey just
trust me I've got this that I would
believe the real cringe-worthy moment
from this entire thing was Trump dancing
now I'm gonna play 40 seconds of Trump
dancing here it's going to feel like an
hour you have not entered some alternate
reality where the the movement of time
has changed it's going to feel like an
hour because it's so difficult to watch
but it's only 40 seconds I promise you
take a look
yeah yeah
Wow
make it stop yeah
I think I've identified what's so weird
about this Jason and it's that trumps
feet aren't moving right he's sort of
swaying
but his feet are completely anchored to
the ground like they like they were they
were inserted into the ground connected
with nails and it makes the entire thing
very weird probably that and you know
I've been to one of these church
services the whole thing is you sing you
participate you participate in the whole
service oh well he doesn't know the
words I mean that's crazy I'm not that I
would either you know I just never think
to pander in this way well once again
I'd say he just dropped the ball here
you know people could have actually his
people could have researched this and he
could have gone there and hit the ball
to the park but once again he got the
ball give the guy a chorus at least that
he can sing when he's in that so you
could spot the fakeness from from miles
away and just complete act of pandering
and hey you know what if I was polling
0% favorability with black people in a
recent PPP poll I'd probably be getting
pretty desperate as well let's take a
break I'm on Twitter at D Pakman we've
got a great show coming up for you today
Warby Parker is offering a free five day
home Tryon to give you the opportunity
to check out their glasses I personally
wear Warby Parker glasses when I'm not
wearing my contact lenses and I also
started with one of these free at home
try ons of five pairs of glasses you can
get your free home try on and support
the david pakman show at Warby Parker
trialed comm slash TDP s I don't really
like going into glasses stores and
trying on glasses while the salesperson
sort of hovers over me and I like more
than 30 seconds to actually figure out
whether I like the glasses so with the
Warby Parker home Tryon I was able to
pick five pairs that I liked put them on
in the comfort of my own home pick the
one I like the most and then Warby
Parker put my prescription lenses in
there for me a lot of people don't know
that the eyeglass industry is controlled
by just a few big corporations that keep
prices very high like three hundred
dollars for prescription glasses high
which is just insane
Warby Parker glasses start at $95 that's
what mine cost and for every pair of
glasses sold Warby Parker distributes a
pair of glasses to someone in need you
can try five pairs and see what you like
check out the at
trial and support our show by going to
Warby Parker comm slash TDP s it costs
nothing